du théâtre à partir du 31 août au
théâtre de l'oeuvre à paris on joue
l'amante anglaise de marguerite duras
mise en scène patrice kerbrat avec
hubert godon jean paul roussillon et
suzanne flon l'amante anglaise une
histoire policière ou suzanne flon joue
la meurtrière justifiant son acte
reportage françoise roy et marie leur
gendre vivante elle était prêt elle dort
on est très bien tous les soirs
également se boucle quand elles
mangeaient quand elle marche est
quelquefois je pouvais pas le supporter
marguerite duras êtes toujours retrouver
une véritable fascination pour les faits
divers les actes de la vie quotidienne
dans l'amante anglaise
il s'agit d'un crime un couple d'une
extraordinaire banalité dont la femme
claire suzanne flon à tuer sans motif
apparent
une cousine sourde et muette qui
vivaient sous leur toit ce que je vous
dis là ça a un rapport avec mon
caractère rien de plus
je dirige un caractère ne pas supporter
les gens qui mangent beaucoup et qui
dorment bien
pas plus c'est un portrait de femme
magnifique femme enfermée dans la
surdité dans le silence muré dans le
silence par l'indifférence de son mari
et qui finit pour tenter de vivre de
survivre de revivre qui finit par tuer
une cousine sourde et muette justement
que diriez-vous des pas de décor pas de
costume une mise en scène sobre trois
acteurs un interrogateur une coupable
un hymne au sens de l'humour un peu de
folie sans doute mais dans tous les cas
une énigme policière comme les aimait
l'auteur ici marguerite duras
s'interroge interroge comme une quête de
soi même ses amis sont bons ce soir
cela est vrai que l'agresseur avait
écrit cette pièce pour vous au départ en
nombre rien maintenant je suis elle
l'avait écrite pour moi j'espère que je
l'aurais jouer à l'époxy madeleine et
c'était madeleine aurait lieu qu'elle
des jouets dont nous bien sûr qui sait
cette amante anglaise pour vous qui la
vivent et dans cet enfermement que de
glaner enfermement maquis c'est pour moi
je serais incapable de le dire parce que
elle est tellement multiples tellement
mystérieux éclair à la fois plus elle
est lumineuse transparente et plus
opaque
alors c'est mais c'est merveilleux a
joué c'est un personnage qu'on en
rencontre rarement théâtre ça perçage
difficile parce que vous êtes isolé sur
scène oui oui
au début ça me paraît très difficile
d'être comme ça c'est un oeil en place
mais je me suis fait avec tellement dans
son monde dans ton univers d'un dense on
imaginait alors j'ai retrouvé définition
de vous dans le dictionnaire du
spectacle vous est frêle féminine voué
aux héroïnes fragiles puis au maire
désespéré ouvertes des espèces est
bizarre vous enfermez vous avez joué à
peu près tous les rôles donc j'ai eu des
rôles très différents les uns des autres
mais justement mère désespérée je pense
qu'elle va votre préférence quand vous
faites un petit retour en arrière où va
votre préférence dans les rôles des
rôles comiques les rôles dramatiques
rôles isolé rôle où il ya beaucoup de
monde que qu'est-ce qui n'ont isolé
j'aimerai pas être tout seul
non j'aime tout
au moment je joue comme j'aime changer
surtout j'aimerais pas m'enfermer dans
un type de personnage et heureusement
les metteurs en scène ne m'ont pas
cantonné dans un type de personnage vous
me pardonnerez de dire que vous avez
plus de 4 fois 20 ans karine et vous
avez toujours ce plaisir renouvelé de
meteab d'apprendre des textes oui c'est
la très niant c'est dur c'est une
lagarde là c'était dur à prendre mais à
jouer c'est un bonheur alors comment
faites vous je m'y colle fait c'est vrai
mais pas chez vous au milieu tout jardin
de nuit mais je copie les choses les
plus difficiles et j'en ai toujours dans
mes poches ou dans mon sac et quand
j'attends je me remets le soir je revois
et puis prennent un petit à petit ça
manque
mais là je dois dire que c'était parti
diabolique satec quand on regarde tout
ce que vous avez fait une impression
vous n'avez jamais soufflé vous ai
jamais fait parenthèse pour pour voyager
pour faire autre chose pour vous
éloigner du théâtre ou de cinéma vous
avez sans arrêt travailler pour nous
spectateurs
oui j'ai quand même eu des regrets parce
que je trouvais pas de choses qui me
plaît des sapins non non je n'avais pas
joué
oui ça faisait quand même temps je suis
revenu de tournée il ya deux ans et demi
mais maintenant janvier il y avait deux
ans et demi pour beaucoup pour préparer
une pièce mais enfin j'ai une autre
définition la flo comme la piaf comme
remus et n'importe qui sublimait par le
talent c'est pour ça qu'elle est grande
c'est jeannot metz joue celui qui avait
écrit prenez sa commande
je vois aussi modestement possibles
notamment depuis dix ans ouais vous
prenez tout très modestement
alors que on vous admire
on s interroge devant votre talent votre
justesse de ton message issu pour rien
c'est le travail ne vous supporte aussi
fierté quand je sais un texte comme
celui là à mon âge d'avoir appris ni ça
ça c'est pas mal là je suis assez
contente de moi mais c'est c'est du
travail vous pensez qu'au fond il y
avait une sorte de don en vous au départ
pas pour tout le monde et fois un don
départ il n'y a pas de doute
auxi apa dont il va t'elle pas d'acteur
je crois pas le travail seul ne suffit
pas il faut les deux le théâtre a
beaucoup changé depuis quelques
décennies
oui les rapports aux spectateurs la
télévision en modifie beaucoup de choses
oui bien sûr comment on vivait sa vie
bling possible tant d'autres comme on
donne les rôles tant qu'on veut bien
noire et a bien fait que je trouve des
choses qui me plaît le théâtre ça marche
plutôt bien maintenant les théâtres et
oui quand il ya de nous presser les
acteurs ni oui ni la télévision ni
cinéma l'ont tué
rien ne purent altan qu'est ce qui vous
étonne ou qu'est ce qui vous plaît pas
dans le monde tel qu'il évolue violence
mais c'est toujours existé je sais bien
mais c'est davantage
c'est une chose qui me révulse
et pourtant quelques fois vous jouer des
personnages violents ah oui bien sûr mon
anglais c'est quand même pas quelqu'un
de oui mais justement comme je suis pas
violent j'ai envie de jouer
des foules quelle est la définition vous
donneriez suzanne flon - ans je ne
donnerai pas je sais pas vous demander
quelqu'un d'autre sauriez pas donner une
définition veut même de moi oui faire
votre cher une sorte de tableau de
vous-même diabète comme ça je suis voilà
j'ai tel défaut telles qualités et des
défauts les qualités mais ils vont me
demander mon entourage que jeune kim
connais tu sais faire épouser pal 17
incroyablement mottet ce nom je suis pas
mauvaise pour partir
on ne peut pas être comédien est
vraiment modestes parce que si on vient
de présenter devant un public et qu'on
pense qu'on mérite d'être regardée et
qu'on peut intéresser les gens donc on
n'est pas tellement mode et merci
beaucoup d'être venu on vous retrouve à
partir du 31 août au théâtre de l'oeuvre
pour l'amante anglaise
avec jean paul roussillon hiver godon et
mis en scène par patrice tabriz car brad
merci c'est un flot la région à la fin
de ce journal